Representa gráficamente la relación proporcional
que se muestra en la siguiente tabla,
En esta tablita de aquí tenemos estos valores de "x",
0, 3, 6, 9 y 12
y estos valores de "y"
¿Cuál es la pendiente de la recta que se
representa en esta relación?
Bueno, antes que nada vamos a graficar y notemos
que cuando "x" vale 0, "y" también vale 0.
Por lo tanto puedo colocar este punto en el 0, 0.
Muy bien, ahora solo tengo que poner cualquiera
de estos otros puntos en su ubicación correcta.
Vamos a hacer uno que tenga coordenadas enteras,
por ejemplo, cuando "x" vale 6, "y" vale 1.
Entonces cuando "x" vale 6, "y"vale 1.
Ahí está el punto en el lugar correcto,
así que esta es nuestra recta.
Pero bueno, también nos preguntan,
¿cuál es la pendiente de la recta que se
representa en esta relación?
O sea, ¿cuál es la pendiente de esta recta?
Pues recuerden que nuestra pendiente, la pendiente
de una recta, se define como el alza entre
el avance o lo que es lo mismo el cambio en
"y"para un cambio en "x" dado o lo que es
lo mismo, el cambio en "y" dividido entre
el cambio en "x".
Así que bueno, si vamos de este punto a este
punto tenemos un cambio en "y" de una unidad,
no alzamos una unidad y eso lo dividimos entre
el cambio en "x" que es de 6 unidades,
por lo tanto, la pendiente sería 1/6, vamos a
ponerlo un... ¡uy!... 1/6.
Y vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta y estamos
en lo correcto.